trois stars de l'équipe ici paris frida
techs dead perny wee b et mariam garba
étaient réunis pour faire la promotion
du handball féminin au cm1 de l'école
louise weys une rencontre qui a fait le
bonheur des enfants
bah ça fait du bien de rencontrer des
personnes connues dans le monde entier
j'en ai jamais vu donc voilà ça fait
plaisir
bah j'en avais jamais vus auparavant et
comme on choisit étudiants le bal en
sport et par na na judée des personnes
qui savaient bien joué la venue des
joueuses étaient aussi l'occasion
d'aborder la question de l'égalité
hommes femmes
seul un tiers des 70 mille licenciés de
handball sont des fans oui ça c'est très
important c'est important de tavares des
jeunes qui
tout comme en se jouant des avoirs
publicité pour notre club et ça c'est
important
issy paris hand affrontera brest le 25
mars au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines avec
l'ambition d'attirer plus de 5000
spectateurs record actuel d'affluence à
ce niveau